[Music]
I'm not gonna lie to you gamers I'm a
little tired I'm a little jet lag I
don't have any G fuel Oh God
but the memes must go on so this is
doing this should be great hey remember
the guy that does the face for the the
meme that just won't die back get it
again this time he's looking front when
no one is raising their hand so the
teacher starts looking around the room
to pick on someone damn it
stop looking at me stop stop the first
guy to kidnap children it must have been
like my crab noises ah just me
okay little kid staring on the bus like
what this up with stupid kids looking at
me don't do it I'll punch a child my mom
turn off the oven in 15 minutes I'm
going downtown for a couple hours me
after an hour
wondering why my room smells like burnt
chicken okay first guy that sat on an
office chair must have been like oh god
this straight one is so uncomfortable I
don't like it's though old people that's
very rude to stare
old people when somebody has a nose ring
old people that you're watching you're a
bunch of hypocrite losers and this meme
proves it this meme gets up next mean
another meme that just can't seem to die
is the FBI is spying on you meme it's
taken many different forms from Mark
Zuckerberg himself to now the Madagascar
penguin it's the same meme the Penguins
of Madagascar season two kawalsky
work for the FBI if I was a penguin
Madagascar and I worked for the FBI this
would be a total
moment when you realize your whip kept
its act that is funny I like that one
haha shower curtains we're the pockets
for phones and tablets so you can stay
connected while wet Wow a wave of FBI
agent must be like snack snack sack sack
my craft noise if everyone had an FBI
agent fifty percent of the world is an
FBI agent ah see I'm really good at the
villager impression I think that's gonna
catch on it's gonna be a thing on this
channel
me wave on their bed goodnight monster
under bed also me kiss left up webcam
good night agent then FBI who's them
well both of them I'm jet like okay I
have I'm tired now we'll change to the
news papi smoke be papi here hello
I do the news oh this to sin we have
news report from Florida I repeat news
report from Florida Florida teenager
arrested again for hitting an RKO on an
alligator can someone stop this madman
from our koe alligators my god what's
she gonna take Florida man my true
successor no more Florida man its
Florida teenager step aside old people
we dab on you or whatever Zoomers do we
for tonight danced all over you gamers
dumb old people but what's that puppy
puppy puppy new news cruel moment an
Australian fisherman uses dead shark has
Fung and smokes it to tune of baby
[Music]
what the Frick is wrong with me
lap cat remember sad news mutt cat dead
someone posted on imager so you know
it's real saying cat went bye-bye
bye-bye lab cat and Internet was sad so
sad it was like making me something like
blue quit cat you were epic like I love
loved cat he was like father to me I
love love cat is rule drive say well as
it turns out love cat isn't dead and I
think it's safe to say labs have been
restored bye bye now I know you've been
sitting here this episode so far asking
yourself one question and one question
only and I gotta be honest with you I'm
doing the same I think we're all doing
the same on three
one two what is Obama's last name thank
you
at least one person guy I've been
thinking about this my entire life what
the Frick is Obama's last name I cannot
remember it this is literally me what is
Obama's name stupid name stinking name
what is it I know it's something
something why did the area 51 Raiders
not get Obama's name they could have at
least done something except I won't
person that in their rude a ramp I give
one person God Obama's first name at
least then it'll be worth it what the
Frick is Obama's last name does anyone
know I don't usually get political okay
liberals Obama is so epic
then why the Frick don't I know his name
we don't get political or anything on
this channel but things ooh buzz buzz
name actually care
yeah it's Obama care of course
what is Obama's last name Barack Hussein
Obama - his last name is - ah thank God
finally person who knows dr. Phil's name
oh god what a stalker Phil's first name
I don't even know it Oh fear son no not
my well many this
Oh person who knows her bombers last
name who now is it guys
okay combat I figure it out Academy its
Academy here's nice name is Academy pull
away the snipers we get we got him
Harambee was trying to tell us all along
quick kid I don't have much time
Obama's last name is ah the monkey died
I thought her Amma was a child a gorilla
died oh this is so sad listen kid I
don't have much time the Krabby Patty
secret ingredient is oh my god we almost
had it
this is civilization if we didn't kill
her Abuk that's right
I'm making her mom it means listen kid I
don't have much time with this secret to
do stand this listen kid I don't have
much time I have information
leveling doc Hillary Clinton and I think
there was one too many right-wing memes
this time I just want to say I consider
myself on the sphere of the political
spectrum just so we're clear maybe we
will never know about much last name
never will we know who Santa Claus real
name never will we know if Luke cat
actually died we never know next meme
Obama meme / Caramba meme gets up okay
gamers have you ever been to the second
page of Google if you're over 18 only
watch surface web fine deep web dark web
mm-hmm page 2 over cove oh my god
God's save anyone that has ever seen
page 2 of Google page 1 of YouTube page
1 of google vidiots does that still
exist first page of Google
I remember YouTube when Google didn't
own YouTube and they try to create
Google video but no one used it so they
just bought YouTube and now everything
is so epic on this site first page of
Google second page oh god I can't look
at it now let's break it all free I'm
not gonna lie I'm free clash page 3
I freaked every page of Google you can't
stop me was that it second page of
Google gets
fart noises and not very good ones
vatican meme can we force this meme
question mark the thing is like I kind
of want to see it happen I know this
beam is terribly forced it came right
after area 51 which was already kind of
dragged out but I really wanted item
Utley want to see what's in the Vatican
archives petition for Europeans to raid
the Vatican while Americans raid area 51
me leaving the Vatican knowing how to
walk on water at sea that's a fake
imagine where you could go you could go
across the Atlantic that would be
awesome no one would do that but still
can Jesus swim if he walks on the water
or is he like stuck on top of it or is
it like in Minecraft when you have frost
Walker on your boots
can you jump in or is it only if you
walk straight out I'm sure it will say
in the Vatican storm the Vatican
archives
it's literally easy ok first entered the
Vatican through the museum's entrance
nearly acceptable to anyone normos can
go there I bet there's people there
right now get in the hotel del belvedere
still accessible s prick get into the
archives nearby might need a trick like
six slightly armed guards up I'm
disappointed that sentence ended with up
but you know either way break into the
secret part of the archives nobody
probably is in there maybe the Pope
naked final boss maybe Jesus Christ
himself who knows that's the point we
don't know Europeans
open secret vault in the Vatican Jesus
just think about all the epic armor you
can imagine pulling out fully stacked
with crosses and that'd be freaking epic
is smacky me leaving the Vatican with a
hand grenade and a freaking happy grade
when I break into the Vatican archives
to free Jesus see that's a thing this is
from Jesus point of view Jesus
if you're watching this and they have
youtube down there we're coming we're
gonna save you don't worry we got you
bro vatican raid on the 24th yes of
december can someone just forces me mon
Zoomers on facebook please so we can get
some traction going thank you
just so i am not legally responsible if
anything goes wrong thank you that it
can mean get said i really wanted to
make a partner it gets a yeah it's time
for everyone's favorite moment here on
main review bonus means with the best
bonus me
but me
[Music]
okay welcome bonus mean you sucks at the
end very epic here is your reward
therapist Kotowski isn't real he can't
hurt you catch our ski catch eager oh
god oh okay it's a I think it's a when
you poop at a friend's house but it
clogs up their toilet we've all done it
this evolved into me frickin problem
okay your mom's so lazy nine years ago
four days ago she took nine years to
finish the joke
BRR does that mean the mom made the joke
now I'm just confused
youtubers be sure to drop a like and
subscribe everyone hey what's that be
sure to drop a like and subscribe guys
thank you so much it means so much come
on I did that ah sound at least you
could do it's like a video that's it for
today's bonus me hope you guys have fun
smash like if you had fun and bro tic
bill you're a little too far away so I
can't really do it but like stick out
whatever you got look closer there you
go oh wait sorry sorry sorry sorry
there's one more one more meme it's
really funny I'll do this one sitting
I'll do this one sitting if that's okay
is this baby right we've seen the the
mean with the baby thank God that eats
the camera it's hilarious but someone
understood that you can edit it I try to
peek through the door man can't make it
can't make it big that's epic sans edit
[Music]
sans baby
[Music]
aren't you glad you stuck through bonus
meme now this is so cool alright how
about this one okay what about this one
[Music]
[Applause]
oh what we got here it's get you up and
take a look at you yeah yeah you good
it's a good name alright gamers bye bye
bye bye
[Music]
you